from The Daily Caller budlight hires
conservative friendly comedian Shane
Gillis in face saving move in a wild
face saving move budlight is partnering
with popular comedian and original
cancellation Survivor Shane Gillis for
an unlikely brand deal both sides
announced on Instagram Gillis who who
sat Saturday Night Live fired hired and
then fired shortly after woke folks
discover jokes he made on his podcast
announced to deal on Instagram excited
to announce partnership with Bud Light
Gillis wrote the deal comes not long
after an appearance on the Joe Rogan
experience where gillson Rogan Rogan
Bandy about whether or not Bud Light can
rehabilitate its image in the wake of
the Dyan M disaster became a joke gills
told Rogan that's tough to overcome
marketing-wise it's tough to get people
to order a Bud Light publicly you're
going to get made fun of so uh Chen
gills is a funny guy he's a not a woke
guy no I don't think he can save Bud
Light I I don't know I I mean like I
don't blame him I guess for taking the
money but I still don't see how regular
people will be anything but embarrassed
ordering Bud Light I mean it was already
embarrassing to begin with
yeah it barely gets you drunk yeah it
wasn't that good well I mean it's a
light beer so you know what's the point
basically uh you just keep it as
survival uh survival food in Li of water
or if you're you drink like 36 of them
you know a little bit of a different
situation I think that's one of the only
reason he accept it too is cuz he had
like a past drinking them and I don't
know you get slightly Tipsy after 36 of
them yeah but uh uh here's the thing
though the parent company owns a lot
more than just Budweiser and Bud Light
and stuff that like that so they don't
really care I mean they lose a little
bit of money but then they can also sort
of cater it to the woke people so that
you have your specific like lgbtq plus
map woke Dei beer and then all your
other brands like nobody even realizes
the same company as the parent company
necessarily because people don't even
look into that sort of thing 99% of the
time so they're still making money that
I I think that's fine you know I'm not a
big fan of the hyper
a consolidation of massive
corporations so Bud Lights on the verge
of death this is this is this is the
just pure desperation there is a
potentially going to be a strike uh Bud
Light bottling plant workers say they
want to make more money budl can't pay
them more money and eer Bush can't pay
their sales are down something like $30
billion how are they going to pay more
do you guys see that story people are
posting it's a meme where it's like UPS
drivers demand better pay win and the
next one is 12,000 UPS drivers laid off
you know over like and it's just like
what do you think was going to happen
the money's got to come from somewhere
these people don't get it like you work
for a company you say hey as 100
employees we all deserve to make instead
of you know 10 bucks an hour 15 they go
okay fire a third of the staff and then
the money from them goes to you yeah
Shane Gillis is being brought on in an
act of absolute desperation if this
strike happens it could be it could be
the the end of Bud Light because all of
a sudden there's going to be a massive
shortage of a beer already nobody wants
or it could be normal izing the market
nobody wanted to buy it in the first
place but it could be Cascade failure
not enough beer is made they struggle to
sell it as it is what little product
they they make doesn't sell they don't
make back enough money to make more and
they can produce less and less and less
as more and more people quit because
they can't get paid to do the job and
then Bud light's gone by June it's part
of their Master uh plan they're going to
Rebrand as a micro
Brewery They yes artificially limit the
supply double the price you know it
could work look that you should get on
their marketing board they should
KS or something oh it also makes me
wonder who aged who else did they
approach for this position like not
maybe he was their first choice nothing
against him but were there other you
know spicy conservative comedians who
were like no I won touch it they're like
Don Jr is not much of a drinker
anded Ted junr quit it in the 80s so
would you take a sponsorship from Bud
Light Sticks no you wouldn't not for any
amount no a billion dollars all the Bud
Light could drink in the world I don't I
don't drink beer now the challenge is
always this right it's it's like I would
not sell sell out to support a Bad
Company doing bad things the question is
first is budlight the worst offender to
where it is like jumping into the pits
of hell and working with the Devil the
second question the answer may be yes
I'm not saying it's not the next
question is if they offer you a
substantial amount of money could that
action which is not the most egregious
thing in the world promoting Bud Light
result in massively more good if it was
something like you know one of the
cartels wanted you to uh endorse their
human smuggling I'd be like yeah I
understand no amount of money is going
to get you to do that but Bud light's
just a crappy company that did a bad
thing if they were to pay you like $10
million you could say I'll take the gig
and give $9 million to insert you know
nonprofits that are working against you
know uh yeah I guess if I could like
send like is it taxfree the 10 million
we're talk after taxes okay then I give
like 9 million to to Gun Owners of
America uh and then make a bigger garden
and say okay and then to make a YouTube
video saying okay I disavow the company
that gave me the money
just but what if they said like look if
Shane Gillis said yes I mean is anybody
gonna boycott Shane Gillis no I didn't
even know who he was he's a funny guy
he's he was on Sat live what what did he
do he made fun of Asians he was
eventually he was ultimately canceled
right yeah he said something in a Santa
bit from way back in the past uh an
accent Chinese he said something like
and I think it was just like a he
generally generally made like an an
Asian uh mimic and it was right as he
got the job on SNL some writer went back
and found something he did like eight
years ago in the past and I have this to
say Saturday Night Live is racist and
that writer who complained should be
fired as an Asian man myself when I
heard Shane gills make that joke it made
me feel
seen and then this writer came and said
he was racist and removed him from the
show here I thought here was a man who
could try and represent me a champion
for your voice and they just took him
out that's they took him away they took
him away because they're racists wait
until all the modern woke people find
out about Mad TV back in
was what was the Mrs Swan Swan oh God
that was great Bobby she still on Family
Guy yeah yeah it's true yeah I did not
think Mad TV was all that funny but I
got to be honest neither is SNL so I
don't know I would choose Mad TV any day
over fair I would because Stuart was
like kind of just the same thing over
and over again but at least when you
watch it you
went Will Will Sasso was the best yeah
Will Elvis yeah they I mean Alex Bin's
fantastic she's Lois on Family Guy yep
and she was Mrs Swan a Chinese woman oh
yeah like the most crazy racist
stereotype of FS Lowered Expectations
yeah Lowered Expectations uh I'm allowed
to like what Shane Gillis his joke
because I am an Asian person but none of
you are cuz you are all white except I'm
sorry you're oppressing me as the py
right now no uh uh uh you know Serge is
allowed to be uh to laugh as well
because on the on the on the on the
privilege hierarchy he's an
African-American so he's actually closer
to the bottom so the skin color doesn't
matter I'm one I'm I'm about as Native
American as as Elizabeth Warren or a
little bit more does that count okay
okay excellent
soter got my n uh something from the
north that's that's worse
up sir we're not going to be able to
laugh at this joke I don't know what to
tell you Canadian Canadian so Foreigner
so that's you get a half a point for
that wait I'm a foreigner I'm a child of
immigrants and you're a woman and I'm
Canadian and British which you know see
everyone at this table has a a lot of uh
a lot of privilege points and we also
know that according to the woke women
have no agency either so even if anac
Clair laughed at the joke it's not her
fault the best part is I have not watch
Matt TV or SNL ever consistently I don't
think I've ever seen anything from Matt
TV so the whole time you guys were
talking was just nodding like wow so fun
great to hear men talk it was uh it was
it was like SNL wasn't live though and
what it came on on on the same time
didn't it I don't know I know exactly it
was it was it was the same uh company
that did like the Mad Magazine which I
think they they stopped making those no
no no they still make them I'm pretty
sure yeah they still oh they they
returned I thought they were going under
they had like they had like a reissue a
while ago my dad my dad used to be
offend of them back in the day and they
had a reissue recently that he gave me
but they made those since the 1950s
they've been forever they got they got
investigated by Hoover's FBI at one
point because they had a board game in
there that uh it was like how to escape
the draft or something I remember
reading about this and you were and and
there was a little thing you could clip
out to mail in to the FBI and some
people are crazy enough to actually do
that and so they investigated William M
gains got called in before the FBI at
one point for
Testimony that's wild yeah they were
both the same time though to answer the
question like they I think they only
started making a show in like the late
'90s ' 80s and then SNL had been around
since like the 70s or whatever but then
eventually Matt TV went kaput at some
point I don't know but well sad with uh
with Sean Strickland you know doing his
funny bit about Bud Light I'm gonna I'm
gonna fix you I'm G to rehabilitate you
and then of course everybody knows he
was robbed at UFC I think it was it 297
I believe it was against dupi where he
clearly won the fight and then they uh
just didn't give it to him he was robbed
uh anyway the question now becomes are
we at the point where conservatives are
like are you are you going to cancel
Shane Gillis like the people who are
saying Bud Light is out nobody nobody
should be working with them ain't nobody
boycotted UFC and ain't nobody going to
boycott Shane Gillis so you've got to
make a a decision are you are
you against Shane Gillis now I mean you
can be I'm not saying you're not allowed
to be I'm just saying I'm not for or
against him and I never really drink
beer so I can't be for against budl
either but this is the question but this
is the point like we're upset with what
budlight did last year there are people
gleefully accepting money from them if
the issue is budlight is a dead company
that no one should support these people
are happily taking their sponsorship I
mean UFC did was like a couple hundred
million 100 million or something yeah
definitely and now Shane Gillis how much
money you think they paid him they
probably they're probably paying him a a
lot of money and I would take it too
he's like he used to be like a big blood
light Drinker before all this stuff even
happened so like that's like a great
payday so it was actually like part of
his brand at one point yeah it
definitely was yeah he's like the
college FR bro I think that's the hard
thing you know there are people you like
is part of budlight strategy right they
they want to make it so you will say
well I like this person so I'll make an
exception to the point where it gets
memory hold and forgotten um attempt to
rehab I think the ultimate people who
pay the price are their workers which is
what we said in the beginning that who
you know the company the Executive Suite
who makes these marketing decisions
maybe some of them got fired or like
suspended or whatever they got moved to
the background for a little bit
separated from the compan company
temporarily but ultimately when they
have to answer to their shareholders
when they don't have Revenue it's the
people who actually bottle or package
the material who pay the price thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net